Iran launches an attack on a u.s.
airbase in Iraq the missiles flopped and
no Americans were killed at least as of
this airing but the question remains are
we at war with Iran we will examine what
the strike means as well as the broader
Trump doctrine then Covington kid
Nicholas Sandman wins a big payout from
CNN as the fake news company settles a
250 million dollar defamation lawsuit
speaking of fake news the media are
spreading lots of it when it comes to
the Australian wildfires and finally the
New York Times asks the right question
and gives a dumb answer in the dumbest
article on the Internet today all that
and more on Michael Knowles and this is
the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
are we at war are we going to war should
we go to war is war ever justified we
will answer all of those questions today
first the facts because from the moment
that this attack was launched last night
from Iran onto these US air bases in
Iraq there was a ton of opinion a ton of
fake news very little in the way of
facts what do we know we know that Iran
lobbed more than a dozen ballistic
missiles at Al Asad Air Base in Iraq
last night that's the bad news
the good news is as of right now
Wednesday morning there are no reported
casualties at all no American casualties
no Iraqi casualties no casualties period
obviously information is coming in and
drips and drabs but that's the latest
that we have you might be confused to
hear that because last night left-wing
media outlets including MSNBC Washington
Post raw story a ton of them were
reporting without any evidence just
baselessly promoting on television and
in the newspaper iranian propaganda that
they had killed or injured 30 americans
80 americans complete fake news
propaganda coming out of iran and MSNBC
takes that propaganda and airs it
without even trying to vet it same thing
with the Washington Post same thing with
Raw Story they said that and they would
at least attribute the information to
Iranian state media but that raises the
question why is the Washington Post just
senselessly regurgitating Iranian state
media while Iran is attacking the United
States why is MSNBC pushing Iranian
state media on their television network
I mean the good thing is nobody's
watching but they were good the good
thing with the Washington Post is
nobody's reading but how reckless how
irresponsible what total fake news what
obvious clear evidence that the
mainstream media would rather take the
side of Iran then take the side of the
duly elected US president because they
don't like him because orange man-bat
will see even before the attack how
clear this was in the New York Times but
those are the facts right now
there was a major lots of smoke lots of
fire missile attack on a US base and yet
nobody has been killed so what does that
mean are we at war are we going to war
what is the point of this attack we'll
get to that in a second first I got to
thank our friends over a rock Auto you
know why I love Rock Auto the main
reason I love Rock Auto is because even
for me I don't know anything about cars
they make it very easy to get auto parts
online always fair prices no gimmicks no
you got to wait for this sale or that
sale they just always fair prices and
their family run business they've been
serving Auto Parts customers online for
20 years which is pretty much as long as
online has been around go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
they've got everything engine control
modules and brake parts two tail lamps
motor oil and even new carpet whether it
is for your classic or your daily driver
get everything you need in a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
rockauto.com is unique it is remarkably
easy to navigate this is a big key to
you can quickly see all the parts
available for your vehicle you can
choose the brands specifications the
prices that you prefer it's got a great
selection I love it it's just reliably
low prices they're not trying to get one
over on you they're always going to give
you the best deal go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck and then in the
little box that says how did you hear
about us you have to write Noelle
Skinner wles
so that they know that we sent you go
check it out rockauto.com
okay so what does this mean that they've
attacked this US base multiple bases it
doesn't mean anything new in particular
actually fewer people were killed in
this attack last night than have been
killed in just the past few weeks by
Iran fewer Americans have been killed as
of late December there had been 11 Iran
linked rocket attacks on US positions in
Iraq including
in
Green Zone over just the past two months
and they produced American casualties
last night was less bloody for Americans
in our conflict with Iran than the
previous two months you might not know
that from watching the mainstream media
or from watching the big fire and fury
that was going on on videotape but
actually it was less bloody for
Americans than the previous two months
what does that mean it means that the
White House strategy on Iran is working
it means that killing Qasem Soleimani
who is probably looking up on us from
the afterlife right now was a good
strategy despite all the missiles and
the fizzles and the fire and the fury it
actually appears to have de-escalated
the conflict with Iran which had been
increasing for the past several months
and really for the past several years
there was a moment where the United
States and Iran cooled their tensions
they were not openly hostile to one
another that this is in particular after
we returned to Iraq in 2014 but the only
reason for that was that we had a common
enemy
the common enemy was Isis and so we both
fight Isis we stopped the hostilities
with one another for that period of time
Isis is dead Trump came in he said we're
gonna kill Isis we're gonna beat the
crap out of Isis and we did we killed
the leader of Isis Abu Bakr al-baghdadi
then Iran starts the shenanigans again
they kill an American contractor in Iraq
they attack our embassy because M
sulemani himself is responsible for the
deaths of over 600 American servicemen
so what do we do we have the opportunity
to get him president Trump makes the
correct decision to take out sulemani
this was greatly feared by the
mainstream media they lost their minds
over this they said this is terrible
this is putting American soldiers in
danger this couldn't possibly be worse
what a terrible escalation what a
provocation first of all it was neither
an escalation nor a provocation because
we'd been dealing with Iranian attacks
on us for years
but then look at the effect of it look
at the actual effect Iran loves some
Rockets into the dirt and they give
heads up according to recent reports
they apparently told Iraq that they were
going to launch this attack and yet
there were no Americans that were killed
as well so how will Trump respond
previously before this attack last night
Trump said you're not going to be able
to predict our response we have the
credible threat of force you thought we
were just bluffing then we took out your
top military general he said that if you
strike us you go and try to kill some
Americans that we will hit not just
military targets not just oil fields but
cultural sites as well everybody freaked
out they said this is a war crime you're
not allowed to target cultural sites I
did not freak out because I speak Trump
I can understand I can interpret Trump
for you maybe it's because I'm from New
York
maybe it's because I've been paying
attention in the last three years but
when Trump says something you've got to
read it through the mind of a guy who at
least had the art of the deal
ghostwritten for him you've got to read
it through the lens of a guy who speaks
in hyperbole who exaggerated s-- who
understands that in order for threats to
work you need to have the credible
threat of violence but you also need to
know when to bluff you need to know when
to hold him you need to know when to
fold them you need to know when to walk
away and when to run and the way that
Trump talks is you just never quite know
what he's being serious about what he's
joking about what is hyperbole and so
did I fear that Trump was going to
attack some 3,000 year old site in Iran
no I don't think he would do that but
maybe he would I mean that's the message
he's sending to Iran which is an
important message that is how Trump
talks that is how Trump should talk I
think it's an effective strategy
he has since walked it back when they
said are you gonna commit a war crime he
was sitting in the White House and he
said no no I probably won't commit a war
crime
would be returned well as I said
yesterday was very interesting they're
allowed to kill our people they're
allowed to maim our people they're
allowed to blow up everything that we
have and there's nothing to stop them
and we are according to a various laws
supposed to be very careful with their
cultural heritage and you know what if
that's what the law is I like to obey
the law but think of it they kill our
people they blow up our people and then
we have to be very gentle with their
cultural institutions but I'm ok with it
it's ok with me I will say this if Iran
does anything that they shouldn't be
doing they're gonna be suffering the
consequences and very strongly I love
this I love to obey the law yeah ok
that's fine by me it's ridiculous
because we should be able to just
absolutely glass the country and kill
all the mullahs but that's okay I'll I
will follow the law this is the way that
you should speak if you are trying to
get the mullahs to pull back their
attacks on US troops you need to keep
them on their toes you need to remain
unpredictable I mean what is on Trump's
mind when he's making these comments
he's saying we just took at their top
general hostilities have been building
for years I want these guys to know that
I will rain down fire and brimstone and
Hellfire and fury if they kill American
servicemen I want them to know that and
so he is conveying that and apparently
it worked because as of right now all
those missiles landed in the dirt nobody
got killed let's hope that that's true I
mean that's this is based on initial
reports let's hope that that continues
to hold regardless until five minutes
ago until President Trump the opinion
that we should take a hard line on the
mullahs in Iran the opinion that these
guys are some of the worst people on
earth the opinion that we should hit
them so hard they've never been hit
harder in the entire history of Iran
was not a controversial opinion until
the left decided that anything Trump did
was terrible Hillary Clinton the guy
that Trump that's the friggin slip the
lady that President Trump beat in twenty
sixteen years ago in the recent past
expressed the exact same opinion on Iran
that President Trump expressed here is
the former future president Hillary
Clinton whatever stage of development
they might be in their nuclear weapons
program in the next ten years during
which they might foolishly consider
launching an attack on Israel we would
be able to totally obliterate them
that's a terrible thing to say but those
people who run Iran need to understand
that because that perhaps will deter
them from doing something that would be
reckless foolish and tragic of course
this is common sense this shouldn't be a
partisan opinion everybody held this
view until the left decided orange man
bad is their organizing principle the
left is currently rallying to the side
of Iran not just on Twitter not just by
pushing Iran wartime propaganda on the
airwaves and in The Washington Post last
night they were doing this even before
you can see it in to obituaries run side
by side in the New York Times on the
same day we will get to that in a second
then we'll get to the Covington kids but
you know that safety is very important
no time has that been clearer than the
last few days
rings mission is to make neighborhoods
safer now you might already know about
their smart video doorbells and cameras
that protect millions of people
everywhere ring helps you stay connected
to your home anywhere in the world so if
there's a package delivery or a surprise
visitor you will get an alert you'll be
able to see hear and speak to them all
from your phone that is thanks to the HD
video and two-way audio features unring
devices it's really helpful in that it
makes you feel like a cool guy because
you're like in the Jetsons and you can
see your home from anywhere if you're at
the office or on the beach but it also
makes you feel very safe when I'm on the
road I'm happy that sweet little release
is a good shot but I want to be able to
know that we can check in on the home
make sure everything
okay as a listener you have a special
offer on a ring starter kit available
right now with video doorbell and motion
activated floodlight camera the starter
kit has everything you need to start
building a ring of security around your
home go to ring.com slash Knowles Canada
wles is ring comm / Knowles camera wles
on the same day the New York Times runs
two obituaries this will show you what
side they are on in our international
conflicts and in our domestic conflicts
the one op-ed is of Qasim sulemani the
world's most notorious terrorist who we
splattered all over the Baghdad Airport
just a few days ago here's the title of
the obituaries Kassim sulemani master of
Iran's intrigue and force dies at 62 the
master of the intrigue the most
interesting man in the world he does
kind of look like the guy from the
commercial who's the most interesting
man in the world he did until you know
master of intrigue and force oh he's so
handsome he's so brilliant he's so
wonderful dies at 62 okay now here is
football legend Sam white Sam Weiss who
was the last coach to lead the
Cincinnati Bengals to the Super Bowl but
who was later fined by the National
Football League for barring a female
reporter from the team's locker room has
died those those are the two tweets
master of a intrigue and force that's
how they refer to the terrorist who
hates America is trying to kill American
soldiers a coach who led the team to the
Super Bowl but was later fined for
barring a female reporter from the
team's locker room that's how they refer
to an American football legend that's
the New York Times for you that tells
you everything you need to know so
beyond the mainstream media which have
lost in my view whatever little shred of
credibility they had left by pushing
Iranian propaganda as they are attacking
our soldiers beyond the question of the
mainstream media question is are we at
war yes of course we are we've been in
war for years decades at this point
we've been in a renewed conflict with
Iran for months
killing sulamani did not start that war
it was a response to the war that Iran
started question is should we be at war
well the trouble with war is that your
enemy has a say you're not the only guy
who gets a say in war you're your enemy
gets to have a part in that decision as
well should we be at war the answer to
that is we must be able to deter our
enemies under Obama we were not able to
deter our enemies and things got a lot
more dangerous and we got bogged down in
a lot more conflicts under Obama when
Iran provoked us and took our sailors
hostage how did we respond did we kill
their top military official no we sent
them pallets of cash and apologized to
them and thank them so much for letting
our sailors go pathetic and it gets us
more bogged down in Quagmire's
under Trump they attack our embassy they
try to deliver us another Benghazi and
we kill their top military official who
was very likely going to be a leader of
Iran someday we must be able to deter
our enemies it would appear that we have
deterred our enemies because their
response to our killing one of the most
important men in their entire country
was to throw some rockets into the dirt
and make a big stink about it and get
their lackeys at MSNBC in The Washington
Post to push their propaganda but
ultimately as of this moment not to kill
any American servicemen or anybody then
the question becomes is war ever
permissible and and this is a question
that's been coming up on the right even
these days as well of course as the left
I expect the kind of moral incoherence
from the left but when it crops up on
the right that troubles me more greatly
because the right is supposed to know
what's going on but you've seen it I
mean there have been people on the right
even on the far right as the media calls
them who who call themselves pacifists
these days they they say war is
basically never acceptable and that is a
morally indefensible position pacifism
seems all really nice and happy and
Huggy and the
it is an indefensible position CS Lewis
the the great theologian the great
moralist he put this very well in a book
called the weight of glory in an essay
in that book called why I'm not a
pacifist the key passage CS Lewis writes
you should read the whole essay it's
really really good
but the key passage is he writes the
doctrine that war is always a greater
evil seems to imply a materialist ethic
a belief that death and pain are the
greatest evils but I do not think they
are I think the suppression of a higher
religion by a lower or even a higher
secular culture by a lower a much
greater evil nor am i greatly moved by
the fact that many of the individuals we
strike down in war are innocent that
seems in a way to make war not worse but
better all men die and most men die
miserably that to soldiers on opposite
sides each believing his own country to
be in the right each at the moment when
his selfishness is most in abeyance and
his will to sacrifice in the ascendant
should kill each other in plane battle
seems to me by no means one of the most
terrible things in this very terrible
world of course one of them at least
must be mistaken
and of course war is a very great evil
but that is not the question the
question is whether war is the greatest
evil in the world so that any state of
affairs which might result from
submission is certainly preferable and I
do not see any really cogent arguments
for that view absolutely right the
question here is not between wonderful
lovely doves who want us all to get
along and those awful terrible war
mongers who are willing to send American
soldiers overseas to go fight in these
endless conflicts that's not the
question the question when you're
looking at these Wars is what is the
least bad option
what is the lesser evil what is going to
protect American interests and secure
peace over the long run and maybe not
just for the next week or two weeks or
three weeks this killing of sulemani is
a great example of it there were many
people on the left and some on the right
some prominent people on the right
who said the killing of sulemani is
indefensible it's gonna lead to all-out
war it's gonna increase hostilities
Trump realized that wasn't true
obviously anything can happen in war but
we were already in a state of war the
question is will responding will
offering the credible threat of violence
will reestablishing deterrence increase
peace and prosperity over the long run
or will it diminish it and it would seem
that taking a lot hardline on Iran
killing their top military guy has
re-established deterrence even once all
the smoke and fire clears from this
missile attack where they send some
rockets into the dirt it's an important
lesson to remember because pacifism is
so seductive it's such a because you
want that you want to seem like a
peacemaker but pacifism is not a
terribly good way to make peace in in
the long run
strength establishes peace strength
deters violence and weakness which is
what pacifism is weakness only
encourages greater hostilities the key
story today I mean the good news is
obviously no reported casualties at this
moment that the strategy worked that
Iran is making a big spectacle but as of
right now things are looking ok that's
the most important thing the underlying
story here is the absolute corruption of
the media the absolute disgusting media
that would air Iranian propaganda but we
already knew that the media were
absolutely disgusting the mainstream
media how did we know that because of
another story that broke yesterday and
this is the greatest domestic news story
of the new year
probably the greatest news story of the
last 12 months
Nicholas Sandman the Covington kid who
was filmed on video standing at the mall
in Washington while a bunch of black
supremacists were screaming awful things
at him and some maniac
Native American activists banged a drum
in his face and this kid stood with
total dignity and just took it stared it
didn't see his ground but didn't provoke
anybody else
this kid was smeared all over the
mainstream media Risa Ashland a former
CNN contributor said he had a punchable
face everybody smearing this kid is AB
racist and a bigot based on nothing that
kid has just settled a lawsuit a
defamation lawsuit with CNN for an
undisclosed amount of money that lawsuit
was initially for 250 million dollars I
can only imagine what this kid got from
CNN if he got 25 million that's amazing
that would be a tenth of the lawsuit
even if we got 5 million I don't know
that would be incredible because he's
also got these lawsuits out at the
Washington Post I believe he's got one
at at NBC he's got them at all of these
media outlets that smeared him as he
should he should take them for all that
they are worth because even after it
came out that the mainstream media had
unfairly smeared Nick salmon they still
didn't recant their terrible reporting
they actually doubled down he did an
interview this kid on The Today Show
NBC's Savannah Guthrie asked him during
this interview after it was clear he did
nothing wrong after it was clear that he
was the victim
she asked him if he wanted to apologize
for any of them feel from this
experience that you owe anybody an
apology
do you see your own fault in any way as
far as standing there I had every right
to do so
I don't I my position and said I was not
disrespectful to mr. Phillips I respect
him I'd like to talk to him I mean in
hindsight I wish we could have walked
away and avoided the whole thing wow
what a terrific response to an absurd
question she says hey okay so yeah we
figured out that it was those black
supremacists who were screaming terrible
things to you and yeah this this maniac
was banging a drum in your face and you
were just sort of standing there so do
you want to apologize
for standing you're not supposed to
stand you're supposed to lie down and
let the left and the mainstream media
trample over you so don't you want to
apologize for steel you're not allowed
to stand you're a Catholic high school
kid who was who was in Washington DC to
demonstrate against abortion and to
demonstrate for life and to try to put a
stop to killing a million babies a year
you're not allowed to stand
you're a terrible terrible person so do
you want to just apologize and he said I
know I'm not sorry for standing at the
National Mall in Washington DC I don't
I'm gonna check my 10 commandments here
I don't yeah I don't think there's any
any commandment against standing
salmon's attorneys Todd Mick murti and
Lynwood filed I was actually more than
250 was 275 million dollar lawsuit
against CNN they said very accurately
CNN was probably more vicious in its
direct attacks I'm Nikolas than the
Washington Post and CNN goes into
millions of individuals homes here I
have to correct them
CNN goes into a lot of airports it does
not go into millions of people's homes
because as far as I can tell not a soul
actually watches CNN but they do go into
a lot of airports for some reason they
go on CNN couldn't resist the idea that
here's a guy with a young boy that make
America great again cap on so they go
after him CNN settles they've still got
these lawsuits at at the Washington Post
NBC Universal those are also for 250
million dollars and they're planning to
sue in that who are the owners of the
national of The Inquirer rather okay
good news I'm very glad to hear it at
the beginning of the Trump era we were
told that the greatest threat of this
moment is to the Free Press
the greatest threat was to those
wonderful people in the mainstream media
facts first we're apples not bananas
that was a CNN commercial we are the
ones on the front line we're defending
the Constitution we're defending BS
these people are horrible they're
horrible horrible people okay like I
know the
generalization it's generally true they
push Iranian propaganda as Iran is
attacking our troops they push Iranian
propaganda on TV and in the newspaper
they go after a high school kid for
wearing a hat that says make America
great again it should be the least
controversial statement in the country
and they smear him they defame him they
just lie about him and usually they
would do it with impunity except now
people are pushing back against them
there should be no one should believe
even for one second anymore they lie
that the mainstream media are brave
courageous defenders of the truth
they're liars there are they're good
individual reporters of course there are
but the edifice the entire system is
rotten to the core and it must be
dismantled and rebuilt again if you want
to have any faith whatsoever in the
institution of the media we got to get
to Hollywood because there is an
amazingly brave man in Hollywood who
he's he is making the choice to save our
entire planet by rewiring a custom
tuxedo a couple of times before
discarding it and getting a new one it's
an amazing story comes to us from the
fashion designer Stella McCartney we
will get to that we will get to some
other lies on climate change we'll get
to the dumbest article on the Internet
today first I got to say goodbye to
Facebook and YouTube go to daily
wire.com you get me you get the Andrew
Klavan sure you get the Ben Shapiro show
you get the amount wall show you can
test questions in the mailbag that's
coming up tomorrow so get your questions
in you get another Kingdom you get if
you get to the all-access tour you get
to speak to us personally on on the
website and you get the leftist tears
tumblr who could ask for anything more
head on over to daily wire.com we'll be
right back with a lot more
take notes everybody get your pen and
paper out and just try to understand the
amazing work of this living martyr
Joaquin Phoenix
the fashion designer Stella McCartney
posts a photo on the Internet of Joaquin
Phoenix she writes this man is a winner
wearing custom Stella because he chooses
to make choices for the future of the
planet
he has also chosen to wear this same tux
for the entire award season to reduce
waste I am proud to join forces with you
X Stella
Wow he I was really upset because
obviously the Sun Monster is going to
destroy the entire planet unless we all
make our sacrifices to the god of carbon
tax credits or something the world was
about to end it was on the brink of
Armageddon and then one man Joaquin
Phoenix
decided to wear a very very expensive
custom tuxedo and that alone the fact
that he would wear a really really nice
high-end custom designer tuxedo that
would be that would have been enough
Diana that would have been enough but he
went further to save our planet he's
gonna re wear it like two or three times
before he gets a new one like two or
three times Wow you know I some people
knock Hollywood these days they say
they're just a bunch of Craven egotists
who prattle on about nonsense and
political silliness instead of just
doing their jobs but Joaquin Phoenix and
Stella McCartney are saving the world I
got to get my custom tuxedo maybe I'll
wear mine four times before I throw it
out and then I can then I can be a
living martyr to a secular Saint
obviously this is a ridiculous story
coming out of Hollywood the only thing
that ever comes out of
what is ridiculous and in Joaquin
Phoenix's defense at the Golden Globes
he actually gave a pretty good speech
about how if you care about climate
change you should actually try to do
things yourself like you know not take
private jets and fly commercial so I
don't really mean to beat up on Joaquin
Phoenix here I do sort of mean to beat
up on Stella McCartney she's the one who
made this ridiculous and stupid
statement but it's indicative of what
we're hearing from the left around the
world look no further than the fires
that are ablaze in Australia really
awful situation in Australia ton of
wildfires over there a lot of animals
being killed people being killed I mean
a really bad situation for weeks now we
have been told that Australia's
devastating wildfires are caused by
climate change
NPR says all these articles how climate
change is affecting Australia's why else
Rios fires ABC how climate change has
intensified the deadly fires in
Australia Washington Post Australia's
apocalyptic fires are a warning to the
world the Atlantic Australia will lose
to climate change BBC is climate change
to blame for Australia's bush fires no
is the answer it's not you know who's to
blame for Australia's bush fires the
people who set the fires because now
we've found out that police have
arrested 183 people in connection with
these fires and they've charged 24
people with deliberately sent setting
the fires they've already charged them
police have taken legal action against
another 159 people among them are 53 who
allegedly failed to comply with the
total fire ban and 47 people who threw a
cigarette or a match on the land and
helped to start the fires of course what
did you think did you think because
possibly at the very very worst case
scenario the earth has warmed like point
zero zero two degrees in recent years
that that was causing all of Australia
to be set on fire or was it the people
who set the fires obviously it was the
people it wasn't
this grand apocalyptic vision of climate
eschatology that produces all of these
models all of which turn out to be bogus
that never actually predict anything New
York City not underwater like the
climate scientists meaning Al Gore told
us it would be Florida not underwater
like the climate scientists meaning Al
Gore and political activists told us it
would be obviously it's the people of
course it is but it doesn't deter them
from pushing this narrative because the
purpose of the mainstream media today is
not to report the news the purpose of
the mainstream media is to push a narrow
specific leftist agenda so those are the
people on one side it push Iranian
propaganda they cover up the news they
try to ascribe major serious news
stories to their own political narrative
rather than to what's actually causing
them and then on the other hand you've
got Trump flawed though he may be Trump
said something the other day that I
think is really important when we try to
adjudicate his presidency or when they
try to figure out where we stand
especially in an election year Trump
said it's one of my favorite quotes he
said since he's been in office he was
giving a speech to some evangelical
Christians and he said quote I may not
be perfect but I get things done we've
done things that nobody thought was
possible we're not only defending our
constitutional rights were also
defending religion itself which is under
siege America was not built by religion
hating socialists America was built by
church-going God worshiping freedom
loving Patriots perfect yes obviously
his statement about America is true I
also love his statement about himself
people call Trump a narcissist people
say he's completely absorbed with
himself he can't see anything beyond
himself he has no sense of what's going
on in the world
he's the worst most Vic and most
unethical most immoral president we've
ever had this Trump have an ego yeah I
think he's got an ego he slapped
his name on every building he's ever
looked at okay this Trump have a healthy
self-confidence yes I think he does but
as for his alleged narcissism
compare it to Barack Obama would Barack
Obama say I may not be perfect ever I
don't think so I think Barack Obama is
the guy who says seriously with a
straight face when I am elected the
earth will begin to heal and the oceans
the sea levels will will recede and
we'll have peace and harmony in the
world he said that with a straight face
Trump says a lot of things about how
he's the only one who can ever do
anything very often though he's kind of
making a joke he's being hyperbolic
because at the same time he'll say
things like this I may not be perfect or
a little while ago he said I have never
had a drink I've never had a beer I may
be the only president has never had a
beer it's probably the only good thing
you can say about me can you imagine if
I drank I'd be the worst
it's almost verbatim what he said he was
making a joke he had a little self
awareness people attack little of the
left attacks Christians who support
Donald Trump they say he's a terrible
example he's not a Christian guess what
the simple statement I may not be
perfect is a profoundly Christian
statement it's a much much more
Christian statement than what we've
heard in recent years for politicians
she met a little touch of humility
beyond the bragging beyond the hyperbole
beyond all the showmanship a little
touch of humility I may not be perfect I
don't have a beer it's the only good
thing you can say about me that that
kind of thing is a keen insight and it
also shows you the the moral clarity
that that humility can give you to say
look I'm obviously a flawed vessel I'm a
flawed instrument here but we've gotten
things done that are really good we're
defending our constitutional rights but
we're defending religion because America
was not built by religion hating
socialists it was built by church-going
God worshiping freedom loving Patriots
that's a beautiful piece of moral
clarity and I think
for Christians who support Trump we've
known that the whole time we say yeah of
course this guy is not some saint on
earth okay the guy is lived a pretty
shady life in many cases but he's doing
good things and he's got a little bit of
self-awareness more than you could say
for a guy like Barack Obama more than
you could say for much of the Republican
field for that matter okay we've got the
dumbest Oracle on the Internet today
we've got to get to it in just our
remaining few moments here because it's
actually asking a very important
question but it gives a very dumb answer
the question it asks Richard Freeman is
a psychology a psychiatrist who wrote
this op-ed said why are young Americans
killing themselves suicide is now their
second leading cause of death it's a
scary number suicide is the second
leading cause of death among young
Americans and this is in recent years
you know just in the past few years
among 12 to 17 year-olds suicide is up
70% so he gives the introduction then he
writes how is it possible that so many
of our young people are suffering from
depression and killing themselves when
we know perfectly well how to treat this
illness there is the problem he's
identified correctly the rates of
depression skyrocketing rates of suicide
skyrocketing among teenagers that's all
very odd but then he makes a mistake he
says we know perfectly well how to treat
this illness and we don't we know how to
treat depression chemically and
sometimes you need to do that we know
how to treat certain symptoms of
depression through therapy but what
about the root cause not for any
individual person but as a social
phenomenon I think that it is no
coincidence that almost directly in the
same timeframe as religion has collapsed
particularly among young people who
largely were raised without any religion
so depression has increased an anxiety
and stress and suicidality and it's true
among the whole US population and it's a
especially true among young people I'm
about to do this show we're launching
the show in addition to my current show
we're launching a show and Praeger you
called the book club and the first book
that we're doing for the book club is
called man's search for meaning by
Viktor Frankl it's gonna be a great
episode with dennis prager Victor
Frankel's thesis in that book is that
man's search for meaning is the primary
motivation in his life the whole book is
about living in this Holocaust
concentration camp and then getting out
and multiple concentration camps and
then getting out afterwards and making
sense of his life man's search for
meaning is the primary motivation in
life now there are competing theories
some say that man's search for sex is
the primary motivation that's the
Freudian theory some say man's search to
impose his will on people is man's
primary motivation that's the Adler
theory there are a lot of different
psychological theories what motivates us
it seems pretty clear to me as Ronald
Reagan quoted Winston Churchill is
saying that when great forces on them
are on the move in the world we learned
that were spirits not animals that the
destiny of man is not measured by
material computations if you are going
to try to treat this terrifying
phenomenon going on in society
especially among among young people
you can't treat human beings as bags of
flesh as clumps of cells we have flesh
we have bodies but we're not merely
flesh we're not nearly our bodies we
also have a spiritual dimension you
might say that man is fundamentally a
religious being we have natural
religious longings every single one of
us the most hardened atheist has
religious longings which is why when you
get rid of traditional religion you
don't just get cold materialist atheism
you get a bunch of kooky superstitions
like the crystals and the chakras and
the yoga and all of the and mercury is
in retrograde and all of this kind of
craziness you know often atheists and
materialists will describe religious
people Christians for instance as
superstitious Christians are some of the
least superseded
people in the world we're the ones who
were trying to ground our religious
longings in fact you know the Gospels
aren't just poetry the Gospels are
journalism and when you take that away
you get some of the craziest
superstitions you've ever heard of I
don't really understand what the crystal
thing is but there a lot of crystals
okay or the New Age religion or Marianne
Williamson remember when she was when
she was running for president in the
Democratic primary she was saying all
sorts of kooky New Age stuff man is a
fundamentally religious being and even
if you're a little skittish about
religion at least acknowledge the
spiritual dimension of life that our
loves and our joys and our hopes and our
dreams and every single thing that
actually matters to us is not material
it's not physical and you were not going
to be able to treat something like
depression you're not going to be able
to treat despair right despair means the
absence of hope
you can't treat hope if you're only
looking at man as a material being
because hope is not material hope is
metaphysical it's immaterial it refers
to the spiritual he goes on in this
article he asks what explains the
epidemic of teen depression and suicide
there are lots of theories but few
definitive answers drugs and alcohol are
always a popular culprit but in this
case they're on unlikely explanation as
the studies stated above controlled for
drug use in addition there's no evidence
of a significant increase in the use of
drugs or alcohol and young people during
this period of course of course the
drugs and alcohol even if they're
involved are a symptom of something else
it's so funny this is a key
characteristic of intellectuals and of
cultural elites and of the mainstream
media in our modern era is they're
intelligent people I'm sure this guy's
got a very high IQ most of the people at
the New York Times a very high IQ you
can yet they miss the most obvious
answers they often totally lack common
sense what is causing depression what is
causing this mental health crisis they
say we're trying to figure out all of
the physical causes but we can't find a
physical cause of course not
because the cause is metaphysical it's
it's immaterial it's
something beyond this world and it
speaks to the natural longings that we
have for something beyond this world the
only way that you are going to
understand your own health your own
psychology politics culture questions of
domestic politics questions of war and
peace like we're looking at right now or
if you examine them not merely on the
physical level not merely as though
we're all just stuff but if you take
into account all of the metaphysical
things that actually matter to us when
you take that into account all of it war
and peace and love and hope and despair
all come into focus all right that's our
show
I'm Michael Knoll sistah Michael Nolt
show get your mailbag questions in see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies director Mike joiner executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey supervising producers
Mathis Glover and Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
assistant director pavel madoski
editor and associate producer danny
D'Amico audio mixer robin Fenderson hair
and makeup Jessa
alvera production assistants McKenna
Waters and Ryan love the Michael Noel's
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]